[Music]
this is bangladesh
it's probably not a country you've heard
a whole lot about
maybe that's because it's kind of hard
to see on a map
geographically speaking bangladesh is a
small place about as big as the state of
illinois
but when it comes to population
bangladesh is the eighth largest country
in the world with 170 million people
that's 25 million more people than all
of russia bangladesh's capital taka is
the ninth largest city on earth more
populated than new york
but a few decades ago bangladesh wasn't
officially called bangladesh it was
actually a wing of another country
pakistan and it was called east pakistan
and there's a really terrible story
about how it got there
a subcontinent larger than the whole of
europe becomes two self-governing
dominions within the british
commonwealth of nations
in 1947 as british india was becoming
independent the british government
announced the subcontinent would be
split in two
in the center there would be a hindu
majority country called india and
outside it with wings on the east and
west there would be a muslim majority
country called pakistan
east pakistan was populated mostly by
bengalis people from this big region
here which had been split between east
and west in the partition
west pakistan was populated mostly by
punjabis pashtuns sindis and a few other
ethnic groups
separated by over 1 000 miles of indian
territory and demographically and
culturally split between groups from
opposite ends of south asia
this was a really weird arrangement in
the years following independence it
turned out not to work too well for
people in the east
even though east pakistan had most of
the country's population they were shut
out of the levels of power the central
government was dominated by people from
the west
the real power in the country was the
armed forces and bengalis only
constituted about five percent of all
military personnel
east pakistan was treated as an internal
colony of the west
the export earnings of its agrarian
industries were siphoned off by the
central government and the region was
neglected in terms of spending
and there was no better symbol of the
east subservient position than language
because even though east pakistan was a
majority of the country's population its
most common language bengali was given
no federal status bengali speakers were
treated like second-class citizens
so in 1970 pakistan held national
elections overseen by a military
dictator named yaya khan and it was on
the basis of this inequality between
east and west that a bengali nationalist
party called the aomi league swept the
election
led by a charismatic guy named sheikh
mujibur rahman the awami league won an
outright majority not just in east
pakistan but in all of pakistan raman
was set to become prime minister of the
entire country
but to the pakistani government that
wasn't acceptable yaya khan thought that
a bengali party couldn't be allowed to
form a government so he refused to
accept the results of course this did
not go over well in his pakistan
the bitterness of poverty and resentment
in east pakistan erupted today in a kind
of civil war sheikh mujibur rahman the
leader of east pakistan declared the
region an independent republic which he
said will be called bangladesh
[Applause]
the pakistani government was furious so
the next night they launched their
response a campaign they called
operation searchlight
they branded it as a program of
pacification to calm the situation and
return things to normal
but their real plan was different
mass murder on an unimaginable scale
and that's where the united states comes
in
bangladesh was not just another story
about the problems of post-colonial
states and artificial borders this was a
story that took place on an
international scale it became a violent
theater of the cold war one in which
america played an active role
yaya khan was a close ally of america's
president richard nixon nixon and his
secretary of state henry kissinger loved
that type of right-wing military
dictator nixon even called khan quote a
good friend
so in the 1960s and 70s the pakistani
regime became one of the largest
recipients of american military aid in
the entire world
most of the planes guns bullets and
bombs at pakistan was now flying into
bangladesh had been generously supplied
to it by the united states and with
those american weapons pakistan
unleashed a campaign of absolute terror
today recognized as one of the most
ruthless genocides of the entire 20th
century
now west pakistan which also has most of
the army is trying to crush the revolt
there are reports of many casualties in
dhaka and other east pakistan cities
when they arrived in bangladesh pakistan
soldiers put the city under strict
martial law rahman was arrested and any
bengali thought to support him was
murdered
yaya khan personally gave the orders
kill three million of them he said and
the rest will eat out of our hands
dhaka became a particularly gruesome
site huge sections of the city were
bombed pakistani soldiers set older
parts of the city on fire with
flamethrowers or bulldozed entire blocks
flat
at the university soldiers massacred
students and teachers
within a few weeks about 75 percent of
the population of taka had fled but the
pakistani military didn't just stop
there the pakistani army and its
collaborators went into the villages
people say the soldiers went wild that
they chose people at random women men
babies shot and ran them through with
bayonets all the women the people say
were raped before they were killed and
their husbands and children were made to
watch their mother's degradation
the numbers are staggering at least
three hundred thousand bangladeshis were
murdered and perhaps as many as one or
two million
between two hundred thousand and four
hundred thousand bangladeshi women and
girls were raped
about 10 million people fled into india
in just a few weeks
one of the largest and most sudden
movements of refugees in human history
a world bank mission found that in every
district there were villages which have
simply ceased to exist
one american official called it the most
incredible calculated thing since the
days of the nazis in poland
a senior american diplomat named archer
blood wrote message after message to the
white house and the state department
alerting them to the genocide and asking
them to stop protecting the pakistanis
our government he wrote has evidence
what many will consider moral bankruptcy
but nixon and kissinger didn't care
that consul in taka kissinger said
doesn't have the strongest nerves archer
blood's telegram got thrown in the trash
so as pakistan was destroying bangladesh
with american weapons nixon and
kissinger knew exactly what was going on
and they weren't angry if anything they
were impressed the use of power against
seeming odds kissinger says pays off
that was partly because of cold war
power politics after all pakistan was an
anti-communist partner and pakistan's
neighboring rival india seen as a soviet
ally so pakistan was an essential
outpost for us interest and his actions
couldn't be opposed and nixon and
kissinger also held really racist views
that led them to ignore the killings
what nixon had to say about indians in
one white house conversation
the most unattractive women of the world
are humans
most muslims sexless not people i mean
people say what about the bible the
goddess is
[Music]
when one american diplomat suggested
cutting off aid to pakistan to stop the
genocide nixon put it bluntly i wouldn't
do that to help the indians the indians
are no goddamn good
what indians really need nixon said is a
mass famine kissinger agreed he added
they are scavenging people
so nixon and kissinger stepped up aid to
pakistan they illegally transferred more
american weapons into the hands of
pakistan through american allies like
jordan iran and turkey the united states
even made an implicit threat toward
india not to intervene by moving a
nuclear aircraft carrier into the bay of
bengal on the coast of bangladesh
and as america assisted the genocide the
situation escalated with so many bengali
refugees flooding across the border
india had to intervene the indian
government gave its support to
pro-independence bangladeshi rebels
fighting the pakistani army pakistan
responded by launching an attack on the
indian air force and the situation
turned into an all-out war
but with indian intervention that war
ended in just two weeks pakistan
surrendered and bangladesh became an
independent country yaya khan resigned
in disgrace
rahman was freed and became the first
president of the independent nation of
bangladesh
the memory of what happened there may
already be growing dim in many of us but
what did happen there will never be
forgotten by the people of bangladesh
especially the women
but in pakistan there was never any
trial of the war criminals
people who had carried out the genocide
got away with it the generals and
politicians who had planned it remained
dominant in national life even in
bangladesh many people who had
collaborated in the genocide continued
to be prominent in public life becoming
businessmen and politicians
and two of the biggest collaborators in
the genocide henry kissinger and richard
nixon were never tried or held
responsible for their role in bangladesh
they had knowingly facilitated a
genocide had joked about it had spoken
positively of its leaders and they got
away with
it i'm nashua zaman for the gravel
institute
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
you